小芬啊
上次你在YT频道上面问
大家喜欢用哪一种油
来炒菜啊
大家常用的是橄榄油
那有6成5的粉丝
他们是使用橄榄油哦
有一成3的人是用苦茶油
也有人用猪油来炒菜
嘿这样子的话
苦茶油跟橄榄油
它的实力可有得拼了
我记得苦茶油
是很多妈妈们
坐月子的时候
会吃的哦
嘿苦茶油不是坐月子才吃的哦
我们这个年纪的人
更要吃好油
顾好你的脾胃
顾好你的心脏和大脑
马上告诉你怎么吃
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
不吃油皮肤烂20年
1食物竟好转
你知道吗
长期缺乏油脂会怎么样
皮肤不只是会变得
干燥粗糙痒
甚至于比同龄人来的
老得快
我来说两个真实的案例
创业家葳老板
曾经在她的
频道上分享
她朋友为了要瘦身
不吃炸物
连蔬菜都要过过水
护肤的乳霜都不敢擦
结果皮肤干燥到
一抓就掉白白的粉了
皮屑都出来了
头皮屑也跟着变多了
哇
哇听到这个例子
觉得好可怕
瘦下来也不会美丽啊
少油还可能让
皮肤引起溃烂
我曾经跟
宋晏仁医师
做过一次节目
他就分享他的一位病患
吃素20年完全不碰一滴油
皮肤溃烂多年还治不好
后来听宋医师说
身体需要脂肪哦
要吃几片五花肉吧
一周以后
皮肤竟然恢复正常了
我跟你分享一款
台湾的国宝油
它叫做苦茶油
它是苦茶树的籽
所榨取出来的油
完全不输橄榄油哦
苦茶油是好油吗
苦茶油对身体
有什么好处吗
马上告诉你
早上这样喝
养胃通便防牙周病
我们都知道橄榄油
可以直接喝
苦茶油
我们也可以直接喝吗
可以
苦茶油有两种
很棒的使用方式
漱口直接生喝
早上刷牙前
你可以先用一点苦茶油漱口
叫做油漱法油拉法
是印度流传千年的
口腔清洁法
它有很多好处哦
能够预防牙周病
减少牙龈的红肿
口腔是更健康
怎么做
早上刷牙前
用10到15cc的苦茶油来漱口
时间大概10分钟左右
再把油吐到卫生纸上
这个时候
吐在卫生纸上的油
变成什么样子你知道吗
乳白色的
代表细菌和杂质等等
都被带出来了
你再用清水来漱一漱口
再刷牙就完成了
哦我有试过
我把苦茶油
放在嘴里漱漱口
感觉很温和
这个方法
有什么功效呢
苦茶油它里面
有天然的抗氧化物
茶多酚
还有维他命E
你用它漱口
减少牙龈发炎
让口腔是更健康
第二个是生喝苦茶油
医师苦茶油什么时候喝最好
那喝多少呢
早上空腹喝一汤匙
但我这个匙很小
大概这个匙只有2cc还不到
所以这个匙子就要用它个
五勺子到六勺子
这样子的苦茶油
是满不错的
你会获得两大好处
第一润肠通便
第二养胃保护胃壁
想顺利排便不只是要喝水
早上空腹喝个苦茶油
帮你把废物排出体外
整天都顺顺顺哦
都舒舒服服的
第二个好处
有人会问苦茶油
真的顾胃吗
苦茶油里面的
单元不饱和脂肪酸和茶多酚
能在胃里面
形成一层保护膜
减少胃酸的刺激
那胃痛胃食道逆流
有胃溃疡的人
也可以喝苦茶油吗
有没有什么副作用
可以
苦茶油就是属于
温和的植物油
胃痛
胃食道逆流
胃溃疡的人
在早上适量的吃苦茶油
帮助胃壁形成保护膜
缓和酸性的刺激
是很不错的养胃方式哦
但如果你是胃食道逆流
比较严重的人
建议你不要空腹喝
可能刺激胃酸分泌
改成拌食物来吃是更养胃
我们这种年长的阿公阿嬷们
更适合苦茶油
因为我们的消化力
已经没有那么好了
脾胃功能也比较弱了
苦茶油能够
养胃好消化又不刺激
哇这个方法
长辈在家
就能试试看哦
实在很实用
又安心
我就很想推荐
给我爸爸妈妈
三叔公
五婶婆啊
早上有空腹喝油或漱口的人
可以留言给我们
告诉我们你的经验哦
心脏不舒服
这样吃油护心稳血压
嘿你知道吗
这种忽冷忽热的天气
是最怕什么
我啊最怕感冒
现在景气差
要是不小心
中了流感
还要花钱
看病耶
不划算啦
没错
不只是流感啊
保暖不够啊
有时心脏也受到刺激
引发心肌梗塞
脑中风等等
尤其你或家人有
三高有心血管疾病
更要守护好你的心胸
第一招
按摩强化心脏的穴位
内关穴很厉害哦
它同时调养心胃和胸部的不适
舒缓胸闷
心律不整
预防心肌梗塞
同时消除胃里头的胀气
内关穴在哪里啊
来把你的手借给我
在手腕横纹往上三个指头
这个两个筋的中间
这里就是内关穴
你每天按一按
心胸胃都一起保护起来
第二招
怎么吃可以顾心脏
吃好的油脂来护心
最简单的懒人法
就用一碗面线
苦茶油倒进去
这样子和一和
嘿吃了暖心暖身又暖胃
一次到位
苦茶油有两个很棒的物质
茶多酚
山茶甙
茶多酚能够抗氧化
降低坏胆固醇
山茶甙
能够降血脂抗发炎
保护血管
护心超有感的
我记得小时候
阿嬷也会用
苦茶油炒菜
那苦茶油
能耐高温吗
当然可以啊
苦茶油能够耐高温
200度到250度没问题
甚至于比橄榄油的
190度还高
你想用它来
煎煮炒炸拌
都可以
料理方便又安心
我们有很多粉丝
都用苦茶油
来炒菜耶
这样苦茶油
跟橄榄油
哪一个比较好啊
它们都很不错喔
实力相当
看你喜欢的用途来选
苦茶油发烟点高
就很适合于中式的料理
大火炒都没问题
橄榄油它的风味很清爽
你用来凉拌做沙拉
就蛮好的是不是
喔我有查资料
这两种油
好像都对心血管
有好处耶是不是
没错
它们都是富含
单元不饱和脂肪酸的好油
尤其是苦茶油
高达79%的Omega-9
比橄榄油还高
帮助血液的顺畅流动
能够稳定血压血糖
减少血管里头堵塞的风险
所以你是有高血脂的人
吃苦茶油就很棒啰
媲美橄榄油
美容界认证顶级油品
我们台湾之光苦茶油
它保湿力很优秀
红到国外去了
日本的美容界
公认它是保养皮肤
和头发的顶级油品
像日本超有名的
椿油洗发精
就是用苦茶油
日本人还直接把它叫做
椿油呢
小芬你来试试看
好
它好像有一种坚果的香气
对果实的香味
好我抹抹看
它感觉是满好吸收的耶
是喔
苦茶油跟人类的分泌的
油脂很接近
抹在皮肤上
是很容易被吸收的
对啊那很不错耶
如果我们把它加在
自己的保养品里
是不是也满棒的
应该是很棒喔
想补却怕上火
进补用苦茶油
伤口愈合快
你在煮月子餐的时候的菜
用什么油啊
你是苦茶油派
还是麻油派
留言告诉我
你们家怎么煮怎么吃
我们有一个
剪辑的同事
她很喜欢苦茶油
她说帮媳妇坐月子
会特别用苦茶油炒菜
给她吃耶
这样补温和又不上火耶
很好苦茶油比麻油更温润
你知道吗
我有的时候煮鱼汤
也用这个耶
喔那也满棒的
不用怕火气大
你家里
有动手术的呀
有身体虚弱的呀
有慢性病的
有贫血的人
都很适合
不用怕燥热
也不用担心长痘痘
还有一个功效
你炒菜的时候
放一点苦茶油
除了让香气更好
还能够缓解伤口的紧绷感
减少疼痛
帮助组织修护
胡医师那苦茶油一罐
我看到都要
1张6个小朋友耶(口误)
苦茶油为什么这么贵呀
因为它很珍贵耶
苦茶油是从这个茶树
就叫油茶树
它的果实
因为它的果实就是苦茶籽
从这个东西来榨出来的
每年只有一次采收季
从开花到结果
要大概10~12个月
差不多一年耶
苦茶油它不像大豆
不像花生
不像葵花籽那样
出油率达40%
100公斤的苦茶籽
最多只能榨出25公斤的油
也就是只有25%的出油率
因为原料少
油又更纯
价格就当然得高啰
那真的是很珍贵耶
喜欢今天的分享吗
帮我分享按赞影片
或加入我们的会员
和我们一起守护健康
你还想看我介绍哪一种油
或食品吗
留言告诉我